[Music]
welcome everyone
to the webinar on sharing on short
notice
where we'll show you how to get your
teaching materials online
with our markdown
so hello we're really happy you could
join us today we know that everybody has
a lot of things going on so we
appreciate you taking the time to join
us this afternoon
my name is alison hill and i'm a data
scientist
and professional educator at rstudio
and i'm desiree de leon and i interned
with allison last summer at our studio
on the education team
and even though we don't have a video
feed in this webinar we promise we are
real-life humans
who are also stuck at home just now like
you all sitting in front of our
computers
and one thing that desiree and i both
have in common is that we ship a lot of
websites
i am a developmental psychologist
desiree is a neuroscientist
neither of us is a web developer but we
both ship
a lot of websites for teaching data
science and here are just a few of them
if you type the short link on the bottom
of our slides it's
rstd forward slash io
or dot io forward slash sharing
you'll be able to see our slides and
follow along in your browser so you can
see all of these links are
also clickable for you each of these
sites was built using our markdown with
different tools chosen depending on what
we needed
so that's us who are you
we think you're an educator and you have
our markdown files that you use for
teaching
but they may be stuck on your computer
and you need to share them easily with
others
without filling up their inboxes and
that's because
you probably have a new classroom space
that looks like this
so sharing needs to be done 100 online
and you might feel like this right now
everything seems to need your attention
but you cannot do everything
so with that in mind today we'd like to
give you a quick tour
of the our markdown tools that you can
use to get your course materials
online on very short notice
we'll show you how to build a course
website to help you teach and reach
learners using
our markdown and friends and our goal is
to give you a quick
boost to help you get your site up off
the ground
with a shareable link so that you can
get on with your teaching
and hopefully avoid crashing in the
process
so why make a course website at all i
think of it as a way first to help me
organize my own stuff
to get all my piles of teaching
documents into some kind of order
and that makes it more reproducible for
myself and for others
but it's also a way to make my teaching
more resilient if i'm organized and
online i can be more nimble when changes
need to happen and a side benefit of all
that is that it also makes it more
shareable
so it makes it easier for learners too
because they see what i see
so we'll be building websites with our
markdown and because of that we'll start
by talking about building a single r
markdown file
so desiree you're up all right thanks
alison
um so let's see
jumping right in uh what does an armark
markdown file look like so here's an r
project folder
for a lab let's say and inside that
folder you'll notice
on our project file and opening that
file in
our studio takes us here where we can
see our single our markdown file
and as i mentioned this is one for a lab
that's going to visualize data from the
museum of modern art so
let's just quickly walk through some of
the key parts of this file
it starts with metadata written in yaml
which is a list of keys on the left
and their values on the right and the
first key you see
is title which is in this case lab o2
moma museum tour
and the last section is all about output
in the yaml
so here the output is an html document
and beneath that we can add options to
our html document for example
a table of contents with the key toc set
to true
so that's the metadata but the real meat
in your markdown file is
text written in markdown and of course
code written in r so these three things
metadata text and code make up in our
markdown document
so of course desiree the real magic
happens
when you click on the knit button and
see your file
turned into html
so when we click on the knit button we
can watch the build happening
in the bottom pane our mark our markdown
document gets processed
and you can see the rendered html file
locally
you can also choose to open it up in a
bigger browser
and explore around by clicking on it
testing a few things out
okay so here's a screenshot of what we
just showed you uh what we knit
and we can see that using the theme key
in our yaml we were able to apply
uh changes to our fonts and colors
and we have this nice table of contents
that's floating off to the side
um but this is still local and stuck on
my computer
a link would make it a lot easier to
share with learners
so how do we start sharing
first we need a web server which is
basically a big computer in the clouds
and
a hat tip to heather nolis for that
analogy
and for this webinar we're going to use
a web server provided by nullify
so we're going to drag and drop that
project folder
into netlify and this is going to put
our web page online
so alison let's go ahead and do our
first drag and drop
happy too desiree so i open up my
browser
go to app.netlify.com
forward slash drop
and i type very slow
and then i'm going to see that little
box where it says drag and drop your
site folder here
i'm going to take that lab2 folder and
drag it right into that box
you can see network by things for a
second and now my site is live
and it gives me a nice random link
friendly borg
that i can now share with whomever i
choose
hooray all right hooray we have deployed
to nutlify
but just as a quick summary of what
happened so we started with an r
markdown file and it was named index
uh we knit this to convert it to
internet ready html to
internet ready html file uh that looked
great but it still only lived locally in
our project folder
so we had to drag and drop it into
netlify
which deployed our page and generated a
link
woohoo okay but this is just
one our markdown file and we want to be
able to share
many our markdown files so
we're going to hike markdown mountain
today
and our goal for the rest of this
webinar is to show you
for our markdown tools that are for
turning a collection
of our markdowns into a website
and we're going to start with the
classic our markdown site
so to make one you just need the our
markdown package installed which is
already done for you if you use rstudio
and here is in our markdown site for a
course about
data visualization this is just a
screenshot but you can go to the link
above it
and actually the moma lab that we just
turned into a web page was one of the
labs from this course
now this course website is a place to
share all of those labs
and the biggest addition that we see
here is a top navigation bar
which allows us to link to other web
pages including ones made with our
markdown like this page with slides and
readings
or other websites like this one here
which goes to a learning management
system
all right so let's build a minimal our
markdown site of our own
imagine that this box on the left is a
list of files that are inside of our art
project folder
and to knit all of these pages into our
our markdown site
you can mouse over to the build tab in
rstudio and then click build website
and after we've done that we see that
it's added a new folder
called underscore site and that's where
all of our html files live
and then we can also see the site we
just built locally
we have a nav bar a theme and in this
case even a drop down menu
so let's look under the hood at some of
these files
and we'll start with index.rmd
index is a special file name in any
website because it always becomes the
home page
so if each of our our markdown files in
our site was a hot air balloon here
index would be the first one you see
and if we take a peek inside index.rmd
we actually don't see anything very
special
in fact you can actually take any
existing our markdown document that you
already have
rename it index and turn it into your
site's homepage
the next file is underscore site.yaml
and this is new
so this file is in charge of tying all
of the pages together
and it's a site configuration file
written in yaml
and let's take a look inside of that
so the first thing you may notice is
that this
is a yaml file so there are no fences
it's just a list of keys and values and
the first key that we see is
navbar and this is what lets you build
your site's navigation
there's a key for title in this site
yaml
and whether we want our links to be on
the left but you could also put them on
the right
and if we want links listed in a drop
down menu we can do that too
from this file and for all the pages you
link to in your nav
bar there's a key called href that needs
to point to an html file
even though you're using our markdown
files as your source you need to make
sure that it's
always going to an html file and finally
we can set up a theme
that will apply to all of the pages
throughout our site
okay and as for
other markdown pages there's nothing
special about them either
as long as you link to a page in your
underscore site yaml
you can take any existing our markdown
file and turn it into a page
in your site so a quiz alison
here is a page uh that's a lab
page in our website what do you think
the yaml for this lab page looks like
oh good question i think that
this yaml has table of contents
toc as one of the keys that's set to
true
and i see it's floating off to the left
so i think toc underscore float is also
set to true
and i see my favorite code download
key so code underscore download i
believe is true also which allows you to
click on that nice little download rmd
button and somebody can download your
source rmd file
okay elton good job that's exactly what
we see
you can set the yaml for each page if
you want
it doesn't only have to be done in the
underscore site yaml file
and if you want to output option if you
want the output options to apply to
every single page
that's when you would choose to put it
in the underscore site yaml file as
opposed
to the individual page but okay so
finally we are ready to share our
markdown site
and we'll do this the same way as we did
before
as a reminder all of our html website
ready pages are stored in this
underscore site folder so this is the
only folder that we need to drag and
drop
so elson can you take it away again i
will
so here we're back at app.netlify.com
forward slash drop and we're dropping
that underscore site folder right
in and we're able to get
a link hardcore goldwasser
great name website
okay thank you so
one thing you may have noticed uh with
what else and just showed you is that
there's a note from netlify and it says
unclaimed sites are deleted after 24
hours
so we have to actually create an account
with netlify to keep our site online
permanently so let's actually go back to
netlify and
do that okay
so we click on that little sign up for
netlify button and you can sign up
with an existing version control account
like github get lab or bitbucket so if
you have one
i encourage you to use those to sign
into netlify because that'll make your
life easier
and uh today we're going to actually
sign up with an email address so
desiree is entering an email address
signing up for an account with netlify
she's waiting on instructions for how to
verify her account
and we have it
and we will be able to own was it
hardcore goldwasser forever
so now it's part of her team on her
netlify account
and your silly named link
is now here to stay all right
great
okay but after i've deployed my site
what happens if i decide that i want to
make
a change so
let's say for example um looking at the
uh at the yaml file on the left side say
that i want to change
my theme to something named united
so once i make that change i need to
remember to rebuild my website
and then
i need to be able to drag and drop again
so let's see what that process
looks like
sorry my mouse has gone missing there we
go
okay okay so
once we've rebuilt our site with the
changes that we want
we can just use that underscore site
folder again but we have to go into
deploys
in our netlify ui and then you see this
little box need to update your site
drag and drop your site folder here so
this means that we get to keep that link
the hardcore goldbosser link
and update the same link with our new
content
so if we drag and drop it again it takes
a second to think and
it republishes so now if we click on the
link we can see that our new theme
the united theme has been applied so it
looks a little bit different but the
link is the same
great
so now you know how to build and update
our markdown sites
and before we move on to the next tool i
just want to highlight
some good and bad points to take away
about using this tool for a course so
some really great things is that the
source stays the same you can
use a lot of your existing documents and
just plop them right in
without having to change much at all and
another really great thing is that you
have these built-in themes you can take
advantage of to kind of give
your site a makeover easily a bad thing
about our markdown sites
is that as you start to add many
different pages
your directory can get really really
full because our markdown sites do not
allow you to organize pages and our
markdown documents into subfolders
so that's just one thing to kind of keep
in mind but with that let's go ahead and
move on to
our next tool which is distill
so our next stop on markdown mountain is
a distilled website
and you'll have to install the distilled
package before you can use it
and i just want to give you a quick tour
of
the distill website
so let's go ahead and press play here
and
um the style of a distilled site is
actually not very easy to change without
css
but it looks pretty slick out of the box
so you can think of distill
as being a little bit like the nerdier
sibling of in our markdown site
it's built for much more technical and
scientific communication
so for example
so for example there is a way to list
multiple authors and their affiliations
you can also include footers and asides
in your distil pages
and there's this really nice way to
display reuse licenses for your
educational content
so those are some of the features in the
distal website that come out of the box
and so now let's build a minimal distill
site of our own
and just like we did with the our
markdown site we're going to use the
build tab
to knit some files that are in our
project directory and once we do that
it's going to create a folder
again called underscore site that's
going to house our html files
here is what our minimal distill site's
going to look like
and just to point out we can also add we
can have a description
we can have those multiple authors we
can still retain that drop down menu
that we also had in our markdown sites
so let's look at some of these files a
little bit more closely starting with
the index page
again this is going to be our home page
in a distilled website
and any existing our markdown document
that you have will do
there's just one edition we need to make
inside of this file
and that is that in the yaml of the
index file we need to be able to add
this line site distill distill website
and it's also nice to include a title
and a short description but
not necessary
and then we also have an underscore site
yaml file
this is still going to be our site
configuration so this should also sound
a bit familiar
and the yaml nav bar keys here are
similar to what we used in our markdown
sites with one important change
the output must specify that this is
going to be a distill
article
and there's one more thing i need to
tell you about distilled websites
you can make part of your just a website
into a blog
which looks like this so essentially you
can have a single page made up of
clickable posts
and each post itself is its own page and
it doesn't need to be built into the
navigation bar
the way that other parts of the our
markdown and distal site
our markdown sites need to be or like
distill sites need to be
and this can be useful in a classroom
setting just if you want to post
different things like announcements and
kind of a running list
sort of way so in order to create a blog
like page we first need to create what's
called a listing page
and um this is in our markdown document
whose only job is to have
a title and then a listing yaml key and
value
and we're going to call our listing page
schedule
and then we have to remember to link
this listing page to the navigation bar
and once we've done within site yaml and
once we've done that
then we're ready to make some some blog
posts
so the most straightforward way to
create a post is to run the code
distill create post and then within the
parentheses you put the title of your
post
and this is automatically going to
create a new folder called posts
uh with a subdirectory for your post and
it will
also trigger a little window to open
with your our markdown file ready for
you to edit
and you can rinse and repeat this
process creating as many new posts as
you'd like so let's go ahead and just
look inside one of those post files
on the left here you can see what i mean
when i said that it creates a little
subdirectory for your post underneath
the posts folder
and all of this is created for you so
you don't really have to worry too much
about remembering the order here but
if we look inside of the the post itself
we see that
the yaml is already automatically
populated for us with the information
that we need
we can edit it if we need to like change
the date or the title
um and the only downside here is that
once we're done creating our post we
have to remember to knit this
post individually um if you don't knit
it on its own then it won't show up on
your
listing page so
once we've created all of our posts we
can then remember to
build our website one last time so that
the listing page
will be updated with any posts that
we've created
and here for example is what our very
minimal
blog listing page looks like so
on the left you see what the listing
page is and then you can click on to any
of those individual
links to see what the post looks like
and just as before once we're ready to
share we can use our old drag and drop
method
so we'll take the underscore site folder
and
drag that in to netlify just as we did
with our markdown sites
so with that we've covered two our
markdown tools and
there's just a couple points i want to
highlight about just still before we
move on to the next
tool really nice things about distill
are
that you have these really great design
features out of the box you have two
content flavors you can have a regular
page
but you can also have this blog like
page which kind of just lets you
show some more chronological content
one bad thing about distill it's it's
just
pretty annoying i guess to have to
remember to knit each individual post
once by one one by one if you would like
to take advantage of the
blog feature but the good thing there at
least is that you don't have to do
anything manual to
make sure that your posts get on that
listing page we created
okay so now for the rest of the tools
allison will be our guide for our ascent
up markdown mountain and we have two
more tools to go
thank you so i'm going to
describe book down now which is another
r package that you need to install
before being able to use it
and as the package name suggests book
down is a way to
build books with our markdown and you
can use it to build an online book
with a table of contents chapters in
fact as many chapters as you want
and lots of bells and whistles that we
won't be able to cover today
but they're all actually covered in the
book down book which you can see here
and it also happens to be a book down
book itself
so you can see that we have a
website here that looks a little bit
different than the our markdown and
distill sites that desiree just showed
us
instead of having that top navigation
bar that allowed us to
navigate and find the different pages on
our site now we have this table of
contents over here in this kind of left
sidebar
so when i click on that little hamburger
menu i can see my
table of contents going up and down and
i can scroll it it's a very long table
of contents but you can see that i have
a lot of materials in here and i can
click around to any of these
and you can see that the right pane
shows me the content of that page as i
click around
so here in a book down book each of
these chapters is actually an r markdown
file
and when i click on it i'm able to see
the content but i can still
access the entire table of contents here
and you can imagine that if you had this
many documents in an are markdown or a
distilled site you would have had to
build them
usually manually into some kind of top
navigation bar and you just don't have
that much real estate going across the
top as you do
with this kind of layout so that's one
of the reasons that book down is really
popular for educators
book down also comes with search built
in so you're able to
search the entire book so this is also
another nice feature that allows you to
leverage your content
so here's an example of a much shorter
book down book that i built
to show you for a demonstration so we
can give you a quick tour of the files
that go into it
so this book has three labs from a
course i taught on data visualization
the first one is about nathan's hot dog
eating contest
the second one is the one that desiree
just showed you at the moma museum tour
and the third one was a lesson teaching
about colors with ggplot using
data about children's production of
animal sounds
so the files in this book project here
are on the left so you can see that i
have a few our markdown
files i have a yaml file it's an our
project
i have some folders and i have a very
important folder
called underscore book now desiree do
you happen to remember
what the output folder was for our
markdown and distill sites
yes i do it was underscore site
yes so with a book down book now our
book is an underscore book so when i
have all of these files that you
see over here in the left pane when i
have all those in a directory
for an r project and i mouse over to my
build
tab and i click on that build book icon
it creates a new folder called or book
and that's where my book now lives
locally
so i'm going to show you inside some of
those files now
so let's take a look first at index.arm
so desiree described this as the home
page for your other
our markdown sites and it's actually the
homepage also for book down
it also happens to turn into your first
chapter
so if you take a look inside it looks
pretty familiar
there's yaml at the top we have a title
a subtitle
an author we also have two new yaml keys
on the bottom and these are critical for
building a book down book
they are site and output so both of
those are necessary for building an html
book like the one we're building now
and then the rest of this file
everything underneath the yaml can be a
regular r markdown file it just also
happens to turn into chapter one
so like with our other sites we also
have a separate
file too so in the apa our markdown and
just
sites that desiree demonstrated you had
a underscore site.yaml file and in book
down
it's an underscore bookdown.yaml file
and this file works in concert
with the index.rmd file to guide how all
of our chapters
fit together so i'm going to recommend
that your underscore book down yaml file
is pretty sparse
the main key that i recommend using for
this yummle file is new
session and i recommend that you set it
to true this means that each of your
our markdown chapters is knit in a
separation
this will make your life easier and will
make it easier for you to troubleshoot
when you're knitting your book building
your book any of the errors that you
see will be a lot easier to debug if
each of the chapters is totally
independent
you might notice that my chapter files
here on the left
are now named with numbers as prefixes
so i have one hot dogs
o2 moma and o3 meow
you can use the book down yaml file to
instead
list the order of your r markdown
chapters
so before it was using the numbered
chapters to determine the order
that the book got built you can also
take away those numbers
from the names of the files and use the
book down yaml
to determine the order of the chapters
as they are presented to you so that's
another way you can use this underscore
bookdown.yaml file
and the chapters themselves i have three
of them here in addition to the
index.rmd
those are each separate our markdown
files but they're with one major change
and that is that each of these chapters
has to begin
with a level one markdown header so here
you see hashtag
moma museum tour each of these chapters
has to start with that
and so that means that none of your
chapters in a book down book
can have its own yaml and so this is
probably the biggest problem for
if you're going to be trying to convert
existing material into book down
it means that you're going to have to
remove the yaml from each individual
our markdown file that will go into a
chapter so each chapter has to start
with a level 1 markdown header and can't
have its own yaml
they actually put in the yaml from the
index.rmd
and so this gives you a little bit of an
overview of what bookdown is doing
so what you make is you make these
separate
r markdown files for each chapter so
here we have
index.rmd and then another rmd and
another rmd and each of those begins
with that level one chapter heading
so those are all your separate r
markdown files and remember that
index.rmd is a special one that also
includes a yaml
the down does when you have this new
session uh
true just in the book down yaml is that
it knits
if these are markdown files interpret
a page so each of those is now
independent
but how do we get to the point where
we're seeing them all together
book down merges them and gives us the
nice
interactive online navigable book that
we see
when we build the book
so how do we share the book once it's
actually written and built
we know our html files live in that
underscore book folder
so this should seem like old hat to you
now
what i would do is go to app.netlify.com
forward slash drop and i can drop that
underscore book folder
into the same spot and that would give
me a link
but you might have noticed that some of
those random domain names are hard to
remember and keep track of i believe the
one that desiree was working with was
called hardcore goldwasser
it's good for flying under the radar but
they're probably not great for learners
and they're probably not easy for you to
share so we can update the domain on
netlify.com
to make the link easier to share with
other people so
in this example our random domain was
stoic babbage
so if you go into the deploys tab on
netlify once you've made your account
you can see that that's my default
subdomain and if i click on options
edit site name then i can change it so
here i'm going to change it to
dataviz book which amazingly was not
taken
so now i have the domain
dataviz.book.netlife.com
and you can see it takes a second but it
has already deployed the new link works
right away
and now because i have an account with
netlify and i've changed that domain
that's my
domain forever i can keep that and i can
always update that as well the way we
showed you earlier
so the best part about book down is that
i think it's hard to get lost in a book
down book it's
um default you think it's going to be
long because you have this big table of
contents in the left side
so that works in your favor people are
used to being able to scroll up and down
vertically in that table of contents
and the search functions help as well
and so since you have more real estate
in the table of contents vertically you
can also add a lot more content
in so it might be easier when you have
longer form content for teaching
as opposed to an r markdown site or a
distill site where you have to kind of
manually build up that site navigation
the hard parts of book down are that if
you're converting
existing our markdown files over to this
new format you're going to have to do
some work to be able to remove those
yamls from your individual files
and start them all with those level one
chapter headers
you may also need to rename your files
and you also still don't get to have
subfolders so
you're still going to have all your r
markdown files in one directory and so
once you get a certain number of these
it can pretty quickly feel fairly messy
so desiree we have made it to the summit
which is we have
yes hooray indeed
so vlog down is a great package for
building custom and unique websites with
our markdown
but it is not for the faint of heart it
is also probably
not the best choice for you to adopt on
complete short notice
because there is a lot to learn but i
wanted to make sure that you know about
it in case you've already tried the
tools that we've just covered so if
you've already tried our markdown sites
distill sites
or book down and you're still not quite
satisfied with the options
and you want something highly
customizable then you may
look down or for other folks who
have a little bit more time to prep if
you're looking at a fall or a winter
quarter class for next year you could
think about making a website using blog
down
so what is blog down it's an art package
that helps you build a website using a
generator
called hugo and the package itself lets
you use the rstudio
ide to build your site and to use our
markdown content to make your site
so one of the best and worst things
about huco
is that you now have access to over
a hundred hugo themes to choose from so
you can get
really creative with so you may have
felt like when you were looking at book
down
sites or distill or our markdown sites
you've probably seen a lot of sites that
look just like those
and there's some benefits to that i
don't think there's anything wrong with
using a default site
but a lot of people want to go a little
bit further and they have
specialized needs that require
specialized solutions
but it's also easy to get very
overwhelmed by the choices
of hugo themes
so for my own course websites and when i
teach
my favorite theme to use is the hugo
academic theme
because it is very well documented and
it's very flexible also
the theme also has built-in search which
is really nice
so here is the documentation theme for
academic it's a demonstration site
you can see that i have a little search
button up at the top
and you can see that there's all kinds
of different content in here and it's
important to remember with hugo sites
when you look at a demonstration site
it's trying to show you everything it's
not necessarily showing you the best way
to lay out everything
so i built a demonstration site for this
webinar
using the hugo academic theme
and porting over my existing content
from the course i taught
on data visualization where i had that
our markdown site that desiree actually
showed at the very beginning
so i converted all of that content over
to blog down to show you what's possible
so here is my blog down site and you can
access it at share
blogdown.net and you can see i have my
nice built-in search
i have this top nav bar and you can see
i have some nice features like being
able to link to
my rstudio cloud perhaps for my piazza
github
you can put all those links in one place
you can also see that i have some
interesting kind of ways to layout
content that are a little bit more
varied
than what we had at our fingertips with
our markdown
distill and book down sites here i've
also
used blog posts to lay out a schedule
and this was inspired by
monet chet and kai rendell's course
website so showing you each of the labs
stacked on top of each other we're gonna
click on
schedule lab the content for that lab
[Music]
you can also see a course a section for
the syllabus
and finally some instructors with
pictures
links all of the things there's also a
resources section here that shows a
different kind of layout where you can
share
different materials with users just
another
different option that's available with
the hugo academic theme
so here if you remember i showed you
this schedule and if i clicked on this
lab o2 the moma museum tour that's
actually
uh the lab that desiree started with
initially
so let me show you what that looks like
you would go to that page and you would
see these two
here lab and what each of those goes to
is actually the lab goes to an our
markdown site so
this is housed within my blog down site
but i didn't have to change anything
about that file i literally just copied
and pasted it over
into a directory in my blog down site
and then i also used sure engine slides
to make my
uh my presentation slides in our
markdown so you can see that i
also copied and pasted those directly
from my rmarc down
site and directory my blog down the site
and then this kit allows me to take
advantage of one of the best benefits of
using blog down for teaching
which is that when i use the add-in to
build my site
so i use the blog down add-in serv site
it creates a folder called underscore
public
and that's the website that i see but
what it also does under the hood for me
is it builds
any other kind of our markdown content
that i have
so i can house my other markdown html
documents in here
as well as my sure engine slides i can
do it all and i can build it all with
one button
which is really nice
so just a quick tour of some of the
files in a blog down project
the content folder is probably the place
that you'll want to dig into the most
your primary our markdown files will
live here you can also use plain
markdown files
the enamel does depend on the theme that
you choose though so this means that
you'll need to change any existing yaml
to adapt to your theme and this is also
how you can kind of get locked into a
theme so once you choose a theme and
blog down
it's tough to switch
sometimes i also stash and build other
markdown documents in the static folder
and if you go to the repository
associated with my demo site
you can see how i did that to deploy
my our markdown labs and my sharing
slides so that's just a taste of blog
down to give you a flavor for the things
that are
possible so the good parts of blog down
is that you can finally now have
subfolders you can have a
content folder organization that might
help you if you have a lot of different
things like
data assignments labs slides
you can also knit anything so you can
have different output formats are
possible
log down also builds on top of book down
so any of the features that are present
in the book book down html format are
also possible in blog down
the bad things in my experience are hugo
hugo is a new dependency that we've
added all the other options that we've
discussed so far our markdown sites
distill and book down
only had an r package that they depended
on but now when you
work with blog down you are depending on
installing
hugo which is a language that does have
different versions
it requires updates there's a bit of
maintenance involved
there's also a more complex directory
structure so with being able to have
subfolders you also
gain more complexity as well so i
wouldn't necessarily recommend this for
short notice but i do think it's a nice
longer term solution
um some general blog down advice i do
not recommend that you update hugo
during your course if you're using blog
down i also do not recommend
that you update your hugo theme during
your course
and i also just generally recommend
don't update anything during your course
based on personal experience so how do
you share your blog down site
the way you would do that is by let's
use
play is by taking that public folder
and dragging and dropping that into the
app.netlify.com forward slash drop you
can see that it's thinking thinking
thinking
and i get a very nice random domain name
nostalgic
so that would probably be tough for me
to remember i could use the trick that
we showed earlier to change that custom
domain name to something more memorable
and here's a shortcut that you can use
as well so if you go to
that repository that i made the share
blog down repository
i created a little button called a
deploy to netlify button now this works
if you're logged into github so if
you're already using github for version
control if you click on that deploy to
netlify button
you can see that what it does is it
allows you to take the same site that
i'm showing you in my repository
you can then uh link it up to your
netlify account so here desiree is
showing
uh logging in to her existing netlify
account
existing github account github account
sorry thank you
and it creates a new repository in her
github
with the exact same files that i had and
it automatically deploys it to netlify
with all the same settings that i had
created so now desiree
has her own copy of my exact same site
with one button
she clicked on the deploy to netlify
button in my repository
her site deploy is in progress it takes
a little while for hugo to build the
site
so insert jeopardy music here while it's
going
there we go stoic snyder is now live so
she can click on that so that's the
exact same site that i just showed you
but now
it's based off source files in her
github repository
deployed to her own url in netlify
stoic snyder and then she can change
that she can edit the files
and she can employ continuous deployment
with netlify which is by connecting your
github account and using github to store
your source files
you can connect that to netlify so that
every time you make a change and you
push to github
the website can automatically update so
this is how i would really recommend
uh if you want to use block down it's
one of the great benefits without
needing to
to worry too much about remembering to
update your site so if you're familiar
with git
and github version control and you'd
like to take a foray into blog down
i recommend that we also listed some
more resources here
at our github repository for this talk
it's at rstudio.education
it's called sharing short notice if you
look in the github issues there as well
i've
made a list of a bunch of different
educational websites course websites
using the different tools so i've tagged
them whether they used blog down
our markdown book down et cetera so you
can see
links to the source deployed version and
to the repository so you can see the
source files as well
so thank you for joining us today we
hope we've left you with some ideas that
you can use now and hopefully later
and we hope we've left you with visions
of awesome course websites that you can
make in the future
dancing in your heads so we're happy to
take some questions now
hi peter will you have explanations for
how to use iframes to incorporate
learner exercises
um that is a very good question desiree
um i believe that you are
the the world's expert in using iframes
to incorporate learn our exercises into
static html websites
yeah so um so i have a blog post that
kind of walks you through
how to do that um it
it it's a little bit involved not
terribly but it does involve
kind of using a little bit of javascript
and some css but in the blog post so you
can go to my blog it's desiree.rbind.io
um and anyway that post will kind of
walk you through the little lines of
javascript
and css that you need to get up and
running um
and that's something that i've tried
using in our markdown sites i haven't
yet tried incorporating
learn r windows for example in syringes
slides or anything like that but it
should work in
in our markdown distill uh blog down as
well
um so that i would i'd point you to the
blog post
there if you want to get started with
that putting the link in there i think
if i can see it i think about
how i send to all okay i think i might
have responded to that okay
so sorry everyone we're also learning a
new uh tech stack today
so um go to webinar
see so teaching question oh desiree you
know the answer to this one
how do you make these great videos such
a simple way to show the code process
without live coding
yeah so the videos um we used the app
cap
kap and it just works really really nice
it gives you the option of
outputting either as an mp4 file
or as a gif so you have those two
options
and actually out of those two options i
really recommend that you use an mp4
file because those are much smaller
files than gifs and it will
it won't weigh down your site as much
and and then you can just embed those
into any our markdown file using a video
tag so i think one other thing that you
did desiree was you also made sure that
your cursor like in the accessibility
settings of your computer you made your
cursor quite large
for doing those videos right yeah that
was within my
operating system you can i just ramped
up the size of my cursor which is really
great and then within the app
cap um there's a preference setting
where you can
uh click show make my clicks
visible or something like that and so
that's what highlights any time that
um you click so that's also really nice
for tutorial videos
that's a really good question too that
we we can uh work up with screenshots
and with videos
we can work up a blog post
location.orgstudio.com blog
um to show how to make those kinds of
videos because i do really like them
uh someone has a question about suppose
i want to modify an html the generated
html file and keep these changes when i
knit later
is it possible to do so um not
really i think my general answer is all
of the
output directories that we showed you
here today every time you rebuild your
site they're going to get overwritten
every time
so if you wanted to have some html that
you wanted to carry through
you can actually use raw html in your
rmd source
files and have them translate into the
generated html file but in general
i wouldn't recommend editing any of the
output directories that we showed so
like for our markdown or distill site
that underscore site folder
book down that underscore book folder
and for blog down it was
the public folder i would never
recommend editing
by hand any of those files because
anytime you want to update your content
those are going to get rewritten for you
is that accurate according to what you
think desiree also absolutely
yeah don't touch anything in those in
those folders because it will
mostly be a waste of your time as soon
as you knit it will all wash away
so but yeah putting putting raw
html into the our markdown file itself
that that works just great and actually
i do that a lot
yeah yes
um let's see
i actually do not know the question can
we interface rmd files with jupiter
notebook
i do not know the answer to that but
that's a really good question that we
can follow up uh
on community with we'll chase down
the answer yeah
let's see um i think i've worked through
the questions
how about this did we answer this one do
you prefer to host the site on netlify
for any specific reason
are there any advantages over github oh
i don't see that question at all thank
you
um desiree do you want to offer first or
do you want me to
um i'll just answer the first part which
i guess nullify because of this drag and
drop feature
makes it really really nice i think
github can sometimes be
intimidating it was for me when i first
started so
uh being able to deploy a website
without having to
understand github or git is a
is a really nice win if you're
especially if you're doing stuff on
short notice
so you can answer the rest allison yeah
i mean i think
um for myself i use github um
frequently for um for education purposes
and so i will say that
i i switch back and forth sometimes i
deploy sites via netlify sometimes i use
github pages
it kind of largely depends for me on on
the kind of project i'm working on
and what kind of link i want to be able
to link out to
and how much i'm updating it so i i tend
to defer to netlify mostly because i
have a lot of sites there and it's a
nicer interface for me and
the majority of my sites are blocked
down and blog down has a nice feature
where
or hugo has a nice feature that's
actually netlify can build hugo sites
for you so when you serve your site
locally
in our studio what your crew what you're
essentially doing is knitting all of
your source files into html or markdown
files
and then netlify can build your site for
you so it's nice because i'm able to
outsource that and that also allows me
to
be able to use github throughout my
workflow a little bit easier with blog
down
but with the other options i i think i
go back and forth i
i do tend to use netlife more but i
wouldn't say it's a completely strong
preference
so desiree you seem like you can see
more questions than i yeah i think i
think i read out any other ones i only
share three
okay here yeah this is very um here's
another question
i created index.rmd but the tab build
site does not appear what do i have to
do
restart our studio um so sometimes it
might not yet detect
uh all the files in there for it to
identify that it needs to
show you that build book or build site
button so restart our studio open that
our proj file again and you should see
that populate
okay great um what does signing up to
netlify
using a version control account why does
signing up to nullify using a version
control account make your life easier
it makes your life easier if you use
github already if you don't use github
already then it may not make much of a
difference to you
but the reason why i say that is because
you can
keep your files that are already in
github and have netlify connect to those
so whenever you
make a change locally on your computer
to your website
you build your site locally you can see
it
you push to github and that's all you
have to remember to do is you just have
to push it to github
and you don't have to do any extra step
to actually deploy or publish your site
so the way we showed you today in this
webinar
was a very manual way it's not a bad way
but it's a very manual way of dragging
and dropping physically that folder
into netlify to both deploy it the first
time
and to update it and so that could wear
on you after a bit if you're updating
frequently if you have a site that's
just kind of done
and you want to share it then that's not
really a big deal but if you're updating
and maybe
adding materials every couple days or
every week
you may want to think about starting to
use version control
but we didn't want to necessarily depend
on that for this workshop because we
wanted to make sure that we optimized
for being able
to share on short notice which for me
does not involve github
agreed um okay here's another question
i actually don't know the answer to this
one it is what if i would prefer
not to use netlify but a university
server to store my material
oh yeah you can do that as well um i did
that uh
all you really need to know is know the
output directory right desiree as long
as you can drag and drop or place that
somewhere
then you've got a hosted website yeah
as soon as i guess yeah as soon as you
have those html files in some place
then then you can use whatever server
you want following the instructions of
whatever that
that server uses but that's why it's
really nice to know where like where the
site actually is
because um it's your source files are in
your project folder but knowing where
the actual website lives
um in a directory is nice because that's
the only folder that you need
to to be able to share
yes okay there are quite a few other
questions here um let's see
are there any questions yeah if you
wouldn't mind i
i uh just to be done on the hour maybe
we could
um transition some of the questions to
um rcd community or uh maybe an article
uh on the education website uh website's
blog
yeah i don't think i've ever seen this
many questions so there's definitely a
lot of interest
and a lot of curiosity so i'll be sure
to get those to you
okay great as quickly as possible
sounds good possible
so thank you for uh the webinar i i
would like to say to the audience um you
know a few people reported some audio
uh and some visual issues yeah um but
it's not a problem we recorded the
webinar
and we'll post it to the resources
rcu.resources.com
webinars as well as email everyone who
registered
for the webinar so everyone will be able
to see the recording as well as
i'm i just posted on our studio
community
discussion thread to continue the
discussion and i've been collecting a
lot of links that you mentioned as well
so people will be able to see some of
those resources you referred to
as well great right awesome
um yeah okay i'd love to give you an
opportunity to kind of tie up and then
it's right on the hour uh for when
people are are looking to
to leave the webinar okay great
well um i will go back in the slide so
everybody can see here's where the
repository is
so github.com our studio dash education
sharing short notice so this is where
our slides actually are so if you want
to go there you can see
our slides our slide files all the
videos all the
images from this talker in there and
then if you go to
the github issues there in that
repository as well you'll you'll see
some more examples where i've linked to
the source code and the
um uh and deployed versions of websites
so you can hopefully get inspired
yeah there are a lot of great ideas
there and we hope that this has been
useful for you
and inspires you to try some websites on
your own if you've been intimidated by
that previously and
um we hope that this makes
building course websites on short notice
a little less painful
thanks everyone thank you